uh mode and our first speaker is Dr
Marvin pritz he is the um Department of
horiculture chair at Cornell University
and he has been the small fruit um
specialist for many years and has done a
lot of work with uh High tunnel growing
with raspberry Beres and blackberries
and Dr pritz I'm going to move it right
to you okay and it's really nice to see
so many people from so many different
places attend the webinar today and I'd
like to compliment Laura on scheduling a
meeting about keeping plants warm and
dry and probably the coldest day of the
year and maybe even a decade for some of
you uh we want to talk about producing
raspberries and blackberries out of
season using High tunnels and a little
bit of greenhouse most of this will
focus on high tunnels and there are lots
of reasons why uh we can use high
tunnels and green houses one is that we
can improve over wintering of our plants
which is probably going to be real
important this year our season is
extended so the fruits are worth more
fruit quality is higher and yields are
greater here's just a photo of uh some
thornless blackberries and some red
raspberries after winter and this often
happens in more Northern climates they
get killed by cold winter temperatures
the new Prime canes grow just fine but
the old canes
die the price off season if you can
somehow bring those crops on earlier or
uh produce them later can be quite High
here's a photograph I took from a
grocery store and you can see $4.99 for
a half pint of raspberries and $6.99 for
a half Pine of blackberries that's
pretty good
money High tunnels are being used all
around the world right now Spain and
Portugal uses them a lot Scotland uses
them and even California most of the
raspberries now are uh growing to crop
under these tunnels not so much for
warmth but just to keep the moisture off
the fruit the quality is so much better
when the raspberries don't get wet even
from Dew even if it doesn't rain so
these are taken off
everywhere uh California will even go to
the extent of putting up wind barricades
because we know that too much wind
damages raspberry plants as well and
this Farm here not only did they chalous
The Raspberries but they put up uh this
netting here to reduce the wind on the
plant so that they produce more ma
Marvin can I interrupt just for a second
I'm sorry um we are having a number of
people say that they don't see any
picture which is an a different um
problem than we've had before so I just
am wondering how is anybody able to see
the video
the okay we have some people that see it
and some people that don't
um okay good so perhaps it is taking a
while to load so thank you very much for
all of your comments um I am hopeful
that those of you that are not seeing it
that maybe it will load in a bit and
um oh uh okay there is somebody that
just said that um so David called you
have said that the Adobe presenter um
maybe it is loading it's just your
connection may not be fast enough and so
I'm
hopeful that you had you were supposed
to add a load in when you Lo when you
got onto the
program okay so I think it's just taking
a while for this presentation to load
I'm not sure why that is perhaps it's
frozen it's it's a big presentation too
there's lots of pictures so so let's
just give it a moment and hopefully
everybody is there okay
great um sorry sorry Marvin I'll let you
continue okay so if you can see the
photograph here you can see what can
happen to a tunnel if you have too much
wind and the wind can be damaging to the
uh tunnels if you don't manage them
correctly but the point I want to make
is that the tunnels are good for
temperature management moisture
management and wind management and and
our plants can really benefit from that
particularly here it says Northeast but
all throughout the Northern Tier of
States uh we have three reasons why we
could use tunnels and lots of other
places around the world only have one
reason and they use Tunnels for that one
reason we have all the possible reasons
to use a tunnel in our climate and so
we've been experimenting with different
ways of using tunnels to grow
raspberries off seon with higher
quality the first um plan I want to talk
about our fall fruiting raspberries
these are plants that produce fruit in
the first year canes they grow up they
flower in the late summer they produce
fruit in early fall and we can start
picking that fruit at least for us or
late August early September and as you
can see from
the figure here we start to pick in late
August we start picking up in September
and just about the time we get into full
production we get our first Frost at the
end of September early October
and uh we're done and that's a shame
because there's a lot more fruit on
those plants now one of the advantages
of a high tunnel is that we can continue
to pick that fruit even after the frost
comes now there are ways of accelerating
a harvest uh without using a high tunnel
and row covers are one way to do that so
when the plants first come out of the
ground you can cover them with a row
cover like you see here and that will
accelerate the growth and they'll
actually produce fruit earlier and yield
faster and when we've done that with
raspberries we can see that without a
cover this is our yield distribution and
a season these are days after August
10th when we put on a cover for April we
bring that crop on earlier and when we
put that cover on in March we can bring
it on even earlier though that's indeed
one way you can accelerate the Harvest
and bring that crop on before that Frost
comes but you have to do that one way at
a one row at a time and this is what we
used to do until the high tunnels came
along where we could cover you know at
least four rows at a time and it was
much more efficient at doing it that way
plus it was easier to pick the fruit
without having to deal with those
individual row covers so our first
strategy with the high tunnel was to
look at uh the thickness of the row
cover by the way was the 6 o per square
foot but it doesn't have to be a heavy
cover we actually looked at heavy and
lighter covers and it didn't make a
difference it just seemed like uh a row
cover worked and plastic over top of the
plants that load to the ground did not
work uh that actually probably made the
plants too hot and raspberries don't
like heat so A rad cover worked better
in that situation than a plastic cover
but when you go to a high tunnel the
tunnels are much higher and you get
ventilation and the temperatures don't
climb to nearly the level they do in a
tunnel as they would in a sheet of
plastic over a low growing
plant so uh the first strategy is to
look at these cultivars of raspberry and
actually maybe even try to delay Harvest
which we would never do in the field but
to try to get fruit later in the season
from when it's normally available so
here's one of our tunnels and it shows a
crop of Heritage Raspberry being
harvested the plants inside there look
beautiful they're vigorous there's lots
of fruit
but the date is October 20th and for
those of you who are from upstate New
York October 20th you know the leaves
are off the trees by then we've had
several hard Frost and plants outside
are done fruiting there's no fruit the
leaves are starting to drop but inside
the tunnel you can see we're just going
gang
busters Caroline is a good variety for
the high tunnel in mid- October you can
see the fruit looks really nice uh we
looked at a bunch of different varieties
to see which ones would do well for us
and we find that you know Heritage does
just great in a high tunnel Caroline
does great Autumn Britain was one we
tried it it's comes on early really well
but then it drops off pretty fast uh
Josephine is another variety that
actually comes on strong later and had
really good flavor and good size so this
is one that we can grow in a high tunnel
without any manipulation and get a
really nice late crop
here's just some yield data over a
couple of years of aut Britain and
Caroline Heritage and Josephine uh
looking at yields Carolina Heritage as I
mentioned before do really well Autumn
Britain not quite so well the one that
was impressive was Josephine not so much
because of Y but the berry size is
pretty remarkable the size of the fruit
is about twice the size of Heritage or
Caroline which is more or less our
standard and the flavor is amazing it's
really really good tastes like a really
strong great raspberry yeah and these
plants are all planted in ground just
like you would normally plant in the
field and I'll show you what we do here
in a
second but yeah they're just planted in
the ground and the tunnels are put up
over the
plants here's Heritage and compare that
to Josephine and you can look at the
weight on here and some of the berries
are coming off at over 7 gram a piece so
we're pretty excited about Josephine's
is a variety for late season one of the
things we wanted to do is have Heritage
come in later too because in the field
we don't want it later but in a tunnel
why not have it later if you got it
protected for a while so we looked at
several different ways of growing a
plants and manipulating the plants uh we
covered the plants with straw in the
early win late winter early spring to
see if we could delay their emergence
from the ground to see if that would
delay their flowering and Fring when
they canes came up out of the ground we
mowed them off and forced them to start
over again when the canes are about 2
and 1/2 ft tall we pinched the tips to
force them to grow branches and that
would slow them down we did the same
thing a little bit later and then we had
our controls that we didn't do anything
to and I'll just show you the tunnel
here uh before it was covered the plants
are grown in the ground about 7t spacing
between the rows uh we mulch them with
straw the first year we also
Incorporated compost into the area
before we planted and we just screw the
plants for uh a year the following year
for our mulching treatment we removed
the snow towards the end of
February on the plots and we replace
that snow with straw to insulate the
ground and hold in the cold and try to
hold the plants back and indeed when we
look later on in the season and when the
plants started to grow we can see that
the ones that were
mulched had were shorter and further
behind the ones that were not mulched
now remember this is intentional because
we want to deliberately delay the Fring
until later if we
can mowing made a big difference you the
plants that we mowed off and forced to
start over again were further behind
than those that were not mowed the
controls and that difference was
maintained uh throughout the
year we also pinched plants and we
pinched a growing tip when they were
about two and a half to 3 ft tall forced
them to grow these lateral branches that
slowed them down a little
bit
and you can see that difference is
maintained
throughout then we had all those
treatments and then uh towards the fall
of the year late summer early fall we
covered the
tunnel the plants
flowered and there we are covering the
tunnel on September 13th the one thing
is you don't have to have these tunnels
covered all the time in this case here
we only wanted to produce the crop late
so if we would have covered them early
it would have brought the crop on
earlier and we really didn't want that
we wanted to see how we could do by
having a late crop so we didn't want
them to accelerate their growth too much
so we waited until September to cover
over the
tunnel and there we are pulling the row
cover over the tunnel pulling it
down and there we are
harvesting uh question came up how's
hmbo top we've looked at HBO top at
Geneva in our variety trial and it does
pretty well in the tunnel too it's just
a little bit uh funky in terms of
picking it it's a little bit hard to um
see the fruit sometimes but in terms of
flavor and size it's a pretty good one
as well one of the dilemmas we have in
these tunnels is they're only so big and
you can't really look at a lot of
different things at one time but I'd
encourage you uh Brett to contact
Courtney Weber at
cw34 cornell.edu and he's got a lot of
data on hbot top along with a lot of
other varieties for the high tunnel
we've just looked at the ones that um
are a little bit more common that we
thought people could get a hold of and
use the one thing we were concerned
about in the high tunnel is pollination
late in the year you know in September
you're going to get bees and we were a
little bit concerned about that but we
found that the bees love the high tunnel
and they come in and droves and just
hang out in the tunnel here are our
bumblebees all over the place uh they
love that cool dry environment keeps
them out of the frost from outside and
we had no trouble with pollination of
our flowers in the house here we are mid
October lots and lots of raspberries
again outside we've had frost already
you see this outside but inside we have
lots of fruit now towards the end of
October early November we sometimes get
nights when it gets down in the mid to
low 20s but only just for maybe one
night and then it warms up again you got
another week or so really decent weather
what we do on those really cold nights
is we know that the plast that single
layer of plastic will not protect the
plants uh when it gets that cold but if
we take a row cover and throw over the
plants for just that night
and then take it off the next day often
that's enough to get the plants to that
one or two cold nights and then we're
done question is why are those bird
scare devices inside that tunnel well
remember we didn't cover that tunnel
until uh September 13th so during the
summer the birds would come in there and
Roost it wasn't so much a problem eating
the fruit as it was we just didn't like
the birds up there pooping on our heads
when we were trying to manipulate canes
and prune and stuff like
that
here we are November 5th in itha picking
pretty decent fruit and we got fruit all
the way up till November 15th and we've
done this for multiple years now and
November 15th is kind of about the end
of the line on the raspberries they'll
still be there but they don't ripen very
quickly so we cut it off then in terms
of how these treatments
worked this blue line here is a control
this is not doing any manipulation and
you can see that right here is when we
would get our first Frost so typically
we'd be done in the field right about
this point here but because we have the
tunnel the plants keep on producing
fruit all the way up till 14 weeks after
August 22nd that's a pretty long harvest
season 14
weeks by doing these pinching treatments
a little bit of late pinching or early
pinching we were able to delay the peak
of production until end of October and
so that was actually kind of a good way
of spreading out the Harvest Peak having
some that you don't pinch and having
some you pinch and it shifts a
production Peak about 4 Weeks
Later the other treatments we that I
explained to you the mulching treatment
and the mowing treatment they didn't do
as well uh so we're not exploring those
any further recommending those any
further but the pinching looks really
good pinching either you know right when
a p is about 2 and 1/2 to 3 and 1/2 ft
tall seems to be about the right time to
do that another Year's Day data same
thing you can see the control plots here
uh Frost comes here we normally be out
of the business just when we're getting
started but we can keep on going with
the controls and with the pinching this
early pinching when the plants are about
2 and a half to 3 feet tall uh shifted
the production Peak later and it really
didn't we didn't suffer that much in
terms of yield here's the yield uh from
the control and with the pinching
treatments and you can see some
reduction but uh not a lot with the
early pinching Berry size wasn't
affected the mulching and mowing
treatments I said didn't do very
well so the second strategy was uh take
these Prime canes and instead of getting
them to fruit late maybe we could cover
the tunnels early and bring them on
earlier and not only that but remember I
showed you the row covers over the
plants in the field when they were just
starting to emerge from the ground well
we thought well could we do the same
thing inside a high tunnel so not only
do the plants when they start up have a
a big high tunnel over them but they
also have a row cover or even a sheet of
plastic over them when they're short and
small and just coming up the ground we
could really maybe accelerate the
harvest season quite a bit by doing that
so we looked at that and this is the end
of the year um when they're starting to
harvest here are our plants in the field
that are growing outside the high tunnel
this is Heritage in the same Variety in
the high tunnel with some of these
treatments and my goodness these plants
grow like crazy in the high tunnel
really really tall and in fact the
Heritage plants grew so much that it was
a real problem harvesting them they were
just a little bit too tall for my short
helper here Jenny so he sometimes had to
stand on a little stool to get the fruit
off the top so did that mean that these
plants here had much higher yield than
these plants that were growing in a
field well we looked at that and the
size of the plant the fruit didn't
really make much difference and the
yields actually didn't really make much
difference either the yields were pretty
good uh no matter if we covered them
early or not the difference was that the
ones that we covered early came on
sooner so the ones inside the tunnel uh
ripened earlier and maybe went a little
bit longer than those in the field where
the Harvest was delayed but for the most
part the yields didn't really change
that
much
the planning of plastic in September for
extended fall harvest the way I
explained earlier gave us 260 half pins
per tunnel applying plastic under the
tunnel in early spring for Accelerated
Harvest brought the crop on earlier but
the yield was just almost
identical the question is since you're
grown those really long canes what if
you saved those canes through the winter
and infed them the following spring
would it make a difference would it be
worthwhile doing how much yield do you
get from doing that so we uh did a study
where we double cropped versus single
cropped these plants both in the
field and in the
tunnel and here's our fall
crop
5600 gam per meter this is uh and then
when we held them over and harvested
again those now flu canes in the summer
we got about 50% more yield by doing
that again you have to overwinter the
canes but we did get an some additional
yield because of that same thing in the
field a far a fall crop and if you hold
it over and harvest those Flor canes the
following summer you get about 50% more
yield maybe not quite that much so um it
might be worth it it might not be I know
our summer helpers didn't particularly
like picking those flues in the
summertime the crop is a little a little
bit shorter and lower a little bit
harder to pick but you definitely got
additional fruit from that the big
difference between the field in the
tunnel in this case was that the yields
were somewhat Less in the field than the
indoor tunnel and the marketable yeld is
better inside the tunnel than
outside a third strategy was trying to
overwinter Tender blackberries and
raspberries in a high tunnel so you know
in year like this we're probably going
to get some Blackberry winterkill for
sure and maybe some raspberry winterkill
and can a high tunnel protect your
plants from that well you know this
tunnel is only just a single sheet of
plastic it's not very
substantial and you know the tunnels
we're using for overwintering are these
peaked tunnels they're not the like the
hay Grove type which is rounded at the
top th that plastic really has to come
off in the fall before the snow hits
these tunnels here are espcially
constructed with a little bit of
reinforced steel the uh pipes are about
4T apart instead of
five but and so it'll hold a snow load
it'll Shed off of these points but um it
is still only a single sheet of plastic
and these tunnels don't have
supplemental heat so if a plant can
survive in there the temperature is
still getting pretty darn
cold but what we found is that not only
do the plants survive in those tunnels
even with a single sheet of plastic but
they really Thrive these are some
thornless blackberries in June it's only
June and the canes are already really
really tall and if you don't do anything
with these canes by the time the end of
the summer comes they can be 15 20 feet
tall it's amazing how well they grow and
here we are looking at this down the
alleyway between the rows and you can
just see these thornless blackberries
just uh really make a jungle there in
fact one of the the challenges is
managing the vegetation on these R uh
blackberries inside the tunnel and
outside and you can see just a
comparison between
outside thornless blackberries and
inside they grow really really well in
that tunnel environment and they over
winter well too and here's a picture
this appeared in our College newsletter
they uh did a little feature article on
high tunnels and you can just see in the
background the amount of blackberries
that are produced in these high tunnels
it's really
remarkable but compared outside there's
not a lot going on in fact we hardly
ever Harvest much of a crop outside but
inside the tunnel they do real well uh
we had a high tunnel at willsboro this
year which is up along Lake Champlain
just south of the Canadian border right
along the Vermont border we grew some
raspberries both inside and outside the
tunnel there harvested them this year
and you can just see the difference
between outside yields in inside yields
there are more than twice as much inside
as outside uh especially for Jewel black
raspberry oncore uh the high tunnel just
made a huge difference in that very cold
climate up along Lake
Champlain this is the back down IFA a
little bit more mild of black
raspberries we don't get a huge increase
in yield when we look at the difference
between outside and inside here about
you know 28 30% greater yield
um size is usually bigger marketable
yields bigger uh Harvest season's longer
but uh the blackberries are what really
respond to the high tunnel between
inside and outside here's some data on
for three varieties Doyle a witch and
triple crown and and every any variable
we looked at whether it be season length
or size of fruit or eel per plant or
percent marketable fruit inside the
tunnel was greater than outside every
variable every case every variety and I
mean the yield differences were huge
basically fruit in these plants outside
you just doesn't do it I mean you might
get a little bit of fruit but boy when
you put them inside a tunnel they just
yield like crazy yields are just so much
greater inside than outside the tunnel
and here's just some yield distribution
curves of uh
doy that's inside the tunnel and outside
the tunnel and you there's no comparison
you don't have to be a statistician to
figure out that there's significant
yield differences between these plants
and these are different years different
varieties and we get the same thing
every time we do it again same data
inside outside the yields are just
remarkably different inside than outside
so I think I've made a case of
blackberries thornless Blackberry can do
really well inside the tunnel the one
problem we've had with those however are
uh rodent damage this year when we went
out in March and April to look at our
plants after a long winter almost all
the in fact all the canes were girdled
just like this from about a foot up
maybe a foot and a half up from the
ground from Rabbits they got into the
tunnel over the winter these nice
Blackberry canes don't have thorns on
them and they fed themselves in the bark
all winter long and we didn't have any
yield from our blackberries this year
because of the rabbit damage so that's
something to watch out for this year the
high tunnels have chicken wire around
them to keep the rabbits out so we'll
see how that
works then our fourth strategy is to
grow primee fru and blackberries under
tunnels now these are relatively new
they were just developed in Arkansas
about 5 years ago these grow like the
Heritage red raspberry except they're
blackberries and the Blackberry canes
grow up and they flower in the late
summer and they fruit in the fall and
give you an opportunity to have fruit in
October now when we grow these plants
outside in IFA we tend not to get a crop
because it's just too late we get a
little bit the r the blackberries are
just starting to ripen but then the cold
weather comes and we're done but if we
could grow these under a high tunnel uh
the plants can keep on growing these
blackberries were developed in Arkansas
so we have to convince the blackberries
that they're still growing in Arkansas
even though it's upstate New York and by
putting them in a tunnel we uh can
convince them to do that so these are
what the blackberries look like in the
fall they look like regular
blackberries and here's our Blackberry
plots and we did some experiments on
them just like we did with the
raspberries we did some pinching of
pranes we did some bending of prices we
had control plots and U we covered the
tunnel late in the summer
we let them flour we let them fruit we
harvested the plots and this is what the
the crop looks like you can see the yel
potential here is pretty good uh the
berry size is really large really big
fruit and the flavor is pretty good uh
these are the treatments We examined to
control the two different pinching times
and bending the canes uh when they reach
the first wire to see if that somehow
would promote more fruiting and earlier
fruiting here's our pinching treatment
same as with the red
raspberries we did some bending
treatments and I don't I don't have the
yield data all done yet but the pinching
treatments work the same way they do
with the red raspberries they actually
in this case seem to increase the yield
a little bit and they uh bring the crop
on a little bit later give you a longer
extended season the bending treatments
didn't work uh very well at all uh so we
won't go back and do that or recommend
that but pinching seems to be a good
thing for these primee fru in
blackberries now the one thing that the
blackberries did this year that the
raspberries did not do is that when the
weather turned cold in October we had an
exceptionally cold and wet October this
year the can the laterals with the fruit
uh well they turn brown They sort of
wilted um we think this is uh stress
injury from the cold temperatures none
of the fruiting none of the laterals
that did not have fruits like the
vegetative laterals exhibited this
symptom it was only laterals with fruit
on it and we think what's going on here
because the October was so dark and cool
that there wasn't enough carbohydrate in
these plants particularly with fruit so
the fruit drew the carbohydrate out of
the plant and the leaves just didn't
have enough carbohydrate didn't have
enough ability to make antifreeze or
whatever they produce to give them
resistance to cold and they just sort of
collapsed so our yields weren't as high
as we had hoped we left a lot of reddish
fruit here in the plants that
theoretically could have been harvested
in a more normal year that had a little
bit more light and heat in
October so one of our biggest challenges
to producing these plants in the
greenhouse or the high tunnel are the
high yields we get and the chalices that
we've used were a bit of a problematic
you know typically in a field you just
get a fence post and you pound it in the
ground and you Bol a 2x4 to it and put a
couple wires in and you're off and
running but the problem inside a high
tunnel is you know it's when your canes
are spread out in a V like that it's a
little bit hard to get down the alleyway
you have no flexibility on adjusting
these and they're just clunky and they
not really that strong actually so we've
been working with a a fella from Indiana
who who has this company called trellis
growing systems is working on this new
kind of trellis that has the capacity to
support the heavy volume of weight that
you get from the prime canes and the
fruit that's produced on those and this
is what this looks like it's a made out
of reinforced fiberglass supposed to be
stronger than steel but it has a little
bit of flexibility you uh pound a post
into the ground about a foot and a
little plate here that holds it a square
you bolt this aluminum piece onto it
that has pins in it and I'll show you
those pins in a minute and you can
adjust the angle of
these trellis arms and then there's
wires here to support the canes they can
be adjusted and slit up and down this uh
TR arm here to any height you want so
that works pretty slick so here's black
raspberries in an open position with
this system and then you can just pull
out the pins and close them up and gives
you more space for walking down the
Alleyway so
open and uh the way you adjust it is you
just pull out the pins move the bar and
then put the pins back in to whatever
angle you want and it's pretty slick
doesn't take up a lot of space he's
developed a way to Anchor them into the
ground it doesn't use a lot of space
around here and that space inside a high
tunnel is pretty valuable and these
wires get pounded into the ground and
there's a little device there that
catches about a foot down and uh
provides support for these posts so they
don't
collapse the rows that we uh produce
here we have our tunnels are the
standard size is 30 ft wide and 20 I'm
sorry and 96 ft long we find that four
rows down the high tunnel is best so
each of those rows are about seven feet
apart 7 and a half feet apart and that
gives you enough space to to work in
between them the tunnels also are the
sides of the tunnels have a 4ft
extension before the bend starts a lot
of tunnels maybe for greens and all
start to bend right away but we have our
sides elevated for feet so we can get
the two end rows of raspberries
relatively close to the walls of the
tunnel uh and you have that height there
this is the website of the company that
we're working with that has this
flexible trell system and the next
presentation fumi is going to be talking
about how to uh use this type of system
Outdoors to bring protection to your
plants if you don't have a high tunnel
and you want to still cover them uh you
can grow them in such a way that they
can bend down and be covered with a high
tunnel provided you have a decent trell
system to do that a high tunnel I'll go
through some numbers here in a second
how much do high tunnels cost our
pre-plant preparation our Tunnel
construction plant establishment
irrigation TRS we spent this
$1,096 I mean we kept really good track
this is how much it costs for everything
to build that tunnel pay in somebody and
everything and say wow you know that's a
lot of money $111,000 for a 30X 96t
tunnel um and then the Harvest the
plants and to produce the crop and all
that we have production costs and
harvesting costs which you're going to
have anyway 4,000 half pints uh per
tunnel 250 a half pint you get about
$10,000 of yield per tunnel but when you
run those numbers out for several years
so the first year you don't have any
money coming in and you spent you know
nearly $112,000 without anything coming
in doesn't sound so good the next year
first year you have fruit you have to
spend some money getting that fruit
harvested you're going to get $10,000 in
sales uh that offsets that initial cost
second year same thing you about broke
even but the nice thing is from about
year three on on you you have very
little cost going into that tunnel
except for harvesting costs and a little
bit of production costs and then you
start running into the black at a pretty
high level we've had these tunnels
looked at by several economists and they
all say he it's about the best thing
we've seen in agriculture in terms of an
investment uh you get payback within 3
years and after that the return is
pretty good every 3 or 4 years you have
to replace the plastic and that cost you
maybe 3 or 400 $ but it's not $3 or
$4,000 it's just a few
hundred we found that that uh help that
$300 or $400 cost every 3 or four years
happens whether you put the tunnel on or
the cover on just for the fall or you
leave it on year round it's about the
same inter uh could you intercrop in
year one and two I suppose you could if
you could um put some maybe um greens or
something like that in there and you
didn't have too many weeds growing
between your Alleyways I suppose you
could that's something we haven't
done uh when we look at the equivalent
yields um we can get about 20,000 pounds
of fruit per acre in a tunnel on a per
acre basis compared to about 2,000 in
the field so the yield differen is
dramatic and why is that well our rows
are about twice as close together in the
tunnel because we're not driving a
tractor down the alleyway our harvest
season is about two two and a half times
long longer and for some reason
physiologically you saw those pictures
the plants just grow better in the
tunnel and the yield per plant just
seems to be so much higher so if you
multiply two by time 2.5 * 2 you get
close to 10 times higher it's remarkable
then the yields are higher I'm sorry the
price you get for fruit off season is
higher than it is in season we have a
store that we sell and uh is pretty
remarkable and the gross revenues
150,000 per acre pretty remarkable
uh this can be done with Greenhouse
production and pots the same way uh we
don't have time to get into a lot of
detail on that but the same principles
hold grow the plants and pots instead of
um in the ground and we have a
production bulletin on our website that
you can read all about doing this too
and that's what that looks like and uh
just to end up I just want to show you
some pictures of some Growers that are
doing this all over the country this is
Michigan uh Washington doing the same
thing some are doing pot some are doing
ground but the principles are sort of
the
same uh Simco
Ontario New Jersey so anyway we're real
excited about the fact that we can
manipulate these raspberries and
blackberries in different ways to
provide fruit over a very long period of
time it seems like we have an opport o
Unity now in the Northern Tier states to
really make a dramatic impact on the
time of year that our berries are
available and get a higher price and
increase our yields and increase the
quality of fruit all at the same
time all right so Laura that's about you
Mar um there was a question about how
often you should replant the high
tunnels tunnels so we have not replanted
our high tunnels yet uh We've we had
five years of raspberries growing in the
tunnels and we haven't seen any decline
in yield or growth or any increase in
diseases over that 5year period so
that's pretty good I can tell you
outside that after 5 years you sometimes
start to see uh the impacts of the
weather and diseases and weeds and
things like that but we don't have to
deal with that in a tunnel so I think
the you know 10 or 15 years I think is
not at all unreasonable for uh keeping
these plants and a tunnel of course no
one's had tunnels that long so we don't
know but I think that's a reasonable
guess and there was a question earlier
and I may have been typing because it
was when we lost the video about the
wind speed of tunnels did you address
that Marvin the the wind it was about
the wind speed um that that caused that
first tunnel that you showed to fall
down oh yeah okay so that was a tunnel
up at Geneva and that was installed in
September one of the Hurricanes came up
through um and the wind speed was around
60 M hour it was a hay grve tunnel and
the hay Groves are three season tunnels
are not Four Season tunnels are not made
to withstand a snow load nor are they
made to withstand heavy winds the
unfortunate thing here was that the
plastic was on that tunnel and the wind
came on a Sunday when no one was around
to take it off so uh ideally that that
plastic would have been folded down and
put in the v's of the tunnel before that
wind came through and just because it
was at the University and it was on a
weekend and we didn't really predict
that high wind they kind of got caught
and a tunnel got destroyed but typically
you can deal with that just by taking
the plastic off before that wind comes
through great and um you know if you
folks can wait the we have a couple more
questions and we will definitely get to
them but I want to make sure that we I
forgot to introduce a couple of polls
and we're going to do them and then
we'll have um Dr teita give his
presentation and I I promise that we
will make sure that everyone's questions
are answered um let me introduce a
couple of these uh poll questions to
help us get a better idea of um The
Experience level of the group and uh
you'll see how to answer them in just a
second
um let me make sure they go in and you
you can just vote and um then when we
get most everybody voting we'll move to
the second one so thank you very much it
just says are you currently growing
raspberries in high tunnels yes I have
more than one season of experience yes I
have planted raspberries in a high
tunnel but of just one season uh no I
have not yet planted raspberries in a
high tunnel but I'm seriously
considering it or no I or I have no
plans on using a high tunnel for
raspberries or blackberries and if
people could just give us that uh
feedback that would be really helpful so
we have about uh half of the group
voting and while you're all doing this
I'll um load up the
next
presentation
all right we have anybody else want to
vote there we've got about 30 people out
of 52 folks that have
voted give you another
second oops um somebody has closed the
poll I'm sorry about that we'll just uh
hide that and then I'll open up the next
one
this one asks if you are currently
growing blackberries and you can answer
that yes you are a
beginner or yes you have been growing
them for many years and need information
on trellising and high tunnel
possibilities uh or no you do not plan
to add blackberries to your crop mix
because of temperature
limitations or no you do not plan on
adding blackberries due to an unknown
Market or you are not currently growing
blackberries but do plan on adding them
to your crop mix and if you would just
give us some feedback that would be
great and we've got about 27 if we can
get up to about that 30 level or so that
would be
terrific all right I'm just going to
close that poll now thank you I have one
more to one more poll um and I
appreciate Dr te's patience here
and this just talks about
um
using adoption of um High tunnels what
has what have been or still are the
biggest obstacles for your adoption of a
high tunnel for a bramble crop um the
initial cost of the tunnel the cost of
the labor involved in harvesting the
crop you not do not know enough about
managing the crop in a high tunnel or
you are not sure that your Market will
support the extended season and or the
increased production that you might get
in high tunnel and you can vote more
than once on
these okay we have a couple people that
didn't have the full view I'm sorry
about
that give you that and if you're an
extension educator um you really don't
need to reply I know that there are a
number of you but if you do have any
aspirations to grow Bramble crops um
we'd love to get some feedback from
you and I think that's
about about it so I'm going to shut that
pod and now I would really like to it's
my pleasure to introduce to you our
second speaker and that is Dr fomi teita
and I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly I'm sorry um he works for the
United States Department of Agriculture
the EG research station and in Caryville
West Virginia um he has been involved in
developing year round culture for
strawberries um utilizing controlled
environment protective covers and
soiless substrates he also has worked on
optimizing production of plantlets in
soiless uh substrates for out of season
fruit production and he studied the
resource uh storage and allocation of
environmental factors that affect
reproductive organ development in
strawberry and blackberry but today he's
going to be talking to us about um
another trellis system for blackberries
and Dr teita I will turn off my
microphone and let you take over from
here
thank you Laura good afternoon
everyone uh I'd like to talk to you
about a unique trellising system we have
developed here to train blackberries to
facilitate harvesting and to
improve uh over reduce winter injury in
both erect and uh trailing
blackberries uh if you have grown
blackberries in the East especially in
the Northeast you probably have seen
plants
look like they shown in the play
a uh where Flor canes in the springtime
develop no flowering shoes so they're
bare in Kill back to the ground uh we
can provide winter protection using the
things I'll be describing this afternoon
as well as use high tunnels and
Greenhouse to grow black berries here in
the
Northeast to uh reduce winter injury and
realze a reasonable amount of fruit in
the summer the following
summer uh let's look at some of the data
published by uh
researchers uh such as the but hardtin
of various
blackberries uh the thornless and semi
blackberries uh when they're exposed to
freezing temperatures under control
laboratory
conditions uh when the buds are exposed
to temperatures around minus 10 Fen uh
Fahrenheit but half the buds will be
killed uh and contrast the trailing
blackberries that have been developed in
the Pacific
Northwest uh show 50% but kill when
temperatures are drop only down to+ 12
Fahrenheit so that the trailing
blackberries are very susceptible to low
temperature uh
temperatures and Marvin uh mentioned
earlier here about how to reduce winter
injury and he talked about using
structur such as green houses and high
tunnels to reduce winter injury uh other
options are one that one consider would
be uh growing cold tolerant
varieties uh there are some that seem to
be uh a little harder than others such
as uh El Hardy from the University of
Illinois and
uh I think the uh Chester thess may do
well in the uh southern
Pennsylvania uh you could also take
action to reduce uh winter injury by
insulating the plants such as using
structures and other uh mulchi material
such as straw plastic foam or just
covering plants with rad cover or ice
and snow in uh certain areas around the
Great Lakes
area and all these
insulation uh would uh insulate plants
from the cold temperatures as well as
protect plants from cold dry Winter
Winds uh i' like to now talk to you
about uh what we have done here at the
current ber for West Virginia in the
last uh 10 15
years uh the Eastern varieties such as
triple crown and
Apache uh do well in uh zone six and uh
they produce 25 to 30 pounds of fruit
per plant in the open system so they do
not require any winter protection to do
well in the Middle Atlantic Coast
region uh however the trailing varieties
from Oregon suffer severe winter injury
in in our
area uh they're typically killed to the
ground every winter I've been told by
Jim ballington at NC State even in North
Carolina uh trailing varieties such as
cscu uh rarely produce fruit because of
a winter
injury
uh cescu as I mentioned uh was developed
by the USDA in Oregon and does Well in
Oregon as well as in various parts in
California and It suffers a severe
injury when temperature drops down to
about 15°
fahit so uh what I'll be talking now is
about this simple winter protection
system we have developed here and it it
emboss the two two ideas that Marvin may
have t have talked earlier is the the
use of this rotating crossarm or RCA
trellis and the application of floating
Roll Cover over the plants in during the
winter
months the uh rotating cross arm TRS the
RCA has a a short post and a long cross
arm that could be rotated about the uh
uh the uh Post in the
ground
okay
like okay uh the here's the post uh in
this case it's about 30 in high with the
cross arm that is about 5T in length and
there are like four or five wires
on this long cross arm and also has a
stationary short arm with a wire to
catch the Lal canes but the but this
main crossarm could be rotated to put uh
to manipulate the canopy of the
blackberry
plant the
uh system we had
developed here uh has been commercial
ized by a trellis growing system in Fort
wi Indiana and they have the uh uh uh
improved version for
sale uh the Tris TGs system has uh
components made of fiber fiberglass and
some uh
uh mle parts and it's has these two arms
one long one that could be rotated and a
short arm to catch the lateral canes and
has a much better uh anchoring system to
keep the post crossarm stabilized uh
during the growing season than the
system we had developed here uh 15 years
ago
what this RCA system does is is that it
is that it allows the blackberry plant
canopy to be man manipulated during the
growing season and to position the fruit
on one side of the uh
row shown here uh that the system allows
about 95% of the fruit to be uh
positioned on one side of the roow
making harvesting more
efficient what the system allows is that
the the uh for Primal canes to grow on
this training wire and eventually allow
the lateral canes to develop on these
Primal canes uh develop many more
lateral canes that are
5 ft or long or more so so that the uh
fooding capacity of that plant is
increased uh tremendously because of the
increased number of axillary buds or
flower buds on the uh long lateral canes
and because the uh the crossarm arm
could be rotated during the growing
season it's possible to uh
to
rotate the lateral canes that are
trained on this long arm to be brought
down close to the ground in a winter
months and then that allows the uh allow
us to place the Roll Cover on this
lowprofile
plant uh
structure how how is this training done
on the RCA trus
of course the blackberry plants have
Primal canes and floral canes and during
the first growing season for the plant
the Primal canes emerge from the uh
crown and
they
grow upright in the in the case of the
uh uh erect and semi erect
cultivars
showing
here and on the r RC trus what we do is
the uh is this once the uh these Primal
canes reach beyond the height of the
training
wire uh which is about 20 to 24 in off
the ground we force them to grow
horizontally as shown here they're bent
and tied to this training wire so that
the Primal anes grow sideways or
horizontally as you could see the tips
of these Primal canes are here instead
of uh growing straight
upright okay Dr teita there's a question
there's a question about the recommended
numbers of buds in each lateral in this
system okay yeah I got the question uh
let's see let me go back one slide and
show you this okay
I I'm not good at using the pointer here
yeah click it on and then hold it when
the button turns dark yeah there you go
okay okay here are the Primal canes uh
theless black bears tend to produce six
or seven Primal canes during the growing
season but we limit the number of prime
that we train on the system to
three all three Primal canes are tied to
this training wire these are the Primal
canes now question was about lateral
canes I'll go to that in a
moment okay here we have maybe four
Primal canes t uh trained up and tied to
this training wire
okay and as these Prim bent Primal canes
reach the adjacent plant which is
usually 5 to six feet away those tips
are uh cut off or tipped which uh
promotes the axillary buds along the uh
horizontal portion of these three Primal
canes to develop and then lateral canes
emerge okay uh in this system we try to
let all the uh lateral canes
develop along the horizontal potion
since we're
leaving training three Primal
canes uh and allowing them to grow maybe
five feet or so and in that 5T length
there could be
uh 20 nodes here this along this
horizontal section and typically you
expect to see about 75 70% of those
lateral or axillary buzs to uh develop
lateral shoots or secondary canes so in
our system we're getting about
uh seven probably of long lateral canes
and since there are three Primal canes
uh we could train
about or 20 lateral canes up on this
long rotating
crossarm so I hope that had answer the
question uh this is photo taking later
in the summer uh early winter
uh showing that in this case we have
trained two Primal
canes and bent them to grow
horizontally and then in this 5 foot
span we have uh about 14 lateral canes
that have developed and they tend to
grow upright if you could you manage
them properly and get tremendous length
on these lateral canes here we got a
lateral cane growing straight up to the
top wire which is about five ft of
of
space so uh in this photo the plants
have were established uh 6 feet apart
within the
row and once the lateral came hands are
tie
to the wires on this long rotating
crossarm the entire crossarm could be
rotated so that the uh the lateral canes
are now very close to the
ground and uh floating Roll Cover could
be uh placed over these
plants shown
here and why do we do all this to grow
blackberries in the Mid Atlantic coast
region as I show you earlier uh
varieties such as cisq and other
trailing black blackberries from
Oregon are so uh tender that they're
winterkilled like here shown with the
Lal canes uh with no growth and that uh
any Fring shoes that develop in the
spring
are are really uh
in scarce on these L canes there are
some flowering shoes or fru in shoes
that develop on the main cane uh or the
horizontal portion of the of the
cane uh another question here is about
cane
breakage uh with this training system we
rarely get uh cane
breakage uh reason is
that by bending the Primal canes
to about 90 degrees and then forcing
them those canes to grow
horizontally and then allowing the
lateral canes to develop more in upright
orientation
uh allow us to rotate the entire canopy
as much as
110° without breaking the uh the main
can because we're not really bending the
cane doing this um canopy manipulation
but uh twist uh twisting the canes so
these canes tolerate more the twisting
than actual bending so we are not
getting much breakage there are some
breakage uh during the uh early or early
summer when the primary canes are being
trained up and then bent to grow
horizontally uh I think we have have
shown that maybe we get about 5% or so
of the Primal canes break because of
mishandling of these uh Primal canes uh
during the bending operation but we lose
very few canes if we lose one of those
Primal canes or break cause break then
we will then yank that cane out and
allow another Prime that emerg from the
crown to take its
place uh but by using this type of
training
system uh we are able to uh get about 14
15 pounds of fruit from cisu trailing
Blackberry which is what uh is about an
average production in
Oregon and in the case of Triple Crown
in Apache which do uh do not need any
winter protection we have
harvested uh about 30 pounds of fruit uh
per plant at 5 foot or six foot
spacing so again uh show on the left
plant uh that was not protected in the
winter and then shown on the right uh
plant that was trained on the RCA
trellis with the can's position close to
the ground and then cover with rotating
with the floating Roll Cover we're
getting uh good fruit
production here are some data from our
uh studies uh performed
between uh year 2002 and uh
2009 uh for variety
ssq we are able
to Advan the bloom by about seven seven
days and and this is because uh this is
caused by the uh application of roll
covers up to uh early March or just
prior to Bud break so by adding a little
bit of fuel heat to the plant in early
spring we're able to uh Advance their
development uh and Achieve as much as
one we uh earliness In Bloom and uh
plants that were trained to the RCA
trellis and then cover with ro floating
Roll Cover in the winter produce 14
pounds of fruit per plant now if you
have the cisu train to a uh conventional
trus or I or tle system and not cover uh
those plants produce less than two
pounds if they are uh trained to a
upright cane training system and covered
in a vertical
orientation uh we got close to 5 pounds
so uh at this low productivity it would
not be worth uh growing uh varieties
such as cisq in the system in here in
the East but if they're trained to the
RCA and covered during the winter months
we can achieve uh much higher
yield there are other benefits to uh RCA
trell
system one is uh that you can Harvest
more fruit in a given time a given time
uh data we have collected in the past
show that as much as 30% increase in
Harvest efficiency this is due in part
to having 90 95% of the fruit on one
side of the row so you don't have to
pick the rows of blackberries from both
sides of the road but concentrate
picking fruit from one side because
almost all the fruit will be position on
one side of the row and if RADS run east
west and you could rotate the whole
canopy to the north side of row uh fruit
will be uh uh in a partial shade or
complete shade and not be exposed to
direct sunlight so there is less sunburn
damage uh some of the temperatures we
have fruit temperatures we have recorded
in the
summertime uh indicated that the fruit
on the south side of the road uh had
skin temperature as much as 20 to 25
degrees higher than the fruit on the
north side of row and imp partial
shade so by having lower fruit
temperature uh probably have a much
better uh pulover sha
life
uh the things I have discussed
today
is a non- tunnel winter protection uh
system uh to reduce uh winter cane
injury and uh reduce uh tissue uh
dissocation during winter
months it can be used to uh extend
Blackberry production to areas with more
severe winter conditions uh places like
uh Northern Pennsylvania New York and
perhaps into New England
states both erect and trading cultivars
can be trained to RCA trellis and
managed for with winter protection to uh
improve uh
productivity so that uh complet it's my
presentation and we could take questions
Dr taita there was one question about um
was the conventional open treatment was
that an open V or a different trellising
system uh in this that study what we did
was to train the uh lateral canes on the
RCA cross arm and then uh left the canes
upright to to the winter months instead
of bringing them down and then either
cover with roll cover or left open uh if
you
train blackberries to other system Pro
probably get a similar results the canar
are ver vertically trained and uh
upright would uh be exposed to um much
colder temperatures than the canes that
are brought down close to the ground and
covered with Roll Cover of snow in the
winter all right does anybody else have
any questions for Dr tequita I know we
had a couple of unanswered questions for
Dr
pritz but now's your chance
folks and it's too cold to go outside
anyway so you might as well ask them
okay what I think there was another uh
question on yield uh we have uh plants
about 700 uh plants per acre density and
in the case of Chester stoneless and
Apache we have harvested about 30 lbs of
fruit per uh yes 30 PBS in the case of
cscq we're uh harvesting around 14
lounds per
plant and since these plantings were
established for mechanical harvesting
many years ago
uh there planting RADS are about 12 ft
apart but uh I'm sure these old these
varieties could be grown at much uh
closer spacing say about a 10ft row
spacing all right that's great um I
don't know Marvin if you're still there
if you maybe as people type in questions
for Dr teita but I know that there was a
question earlier about the use of
movable tunnels with raspberries or
blackberries do you have any comments
about
that we don't have any experience with
that but uh theoretically it's an
intriguing idea uh particularly if you
had the summer blackberries and the fall
blackberries or summer raspberries and
fall blackberries you could move the
tunnel over the fall berries for just
that late season crop for say from
September through November to when you
were done and then you could slide the
tunnel back over the florane Fring crop
that needed the winter protection and
use it for that so you get double use
out of the tunnel if you could have a
rail system or something like that to
slide it back and forth so or you know
not even raspberries but you know greens
or something that needed some winter
protection so yeah it's an intriguing
idea we haven't done it but people are
talking about it and uh it'll be
interesting the next couple of years to
see if people figured out ways to make
um I think there's a question here for
Dr taito what is the best orientation to
the sun uh in your opinion for those
blackberries well if the uh if you are
using the RCA
trus
we're recommending that the rose be
established East West orientation so
that the fruit could be positioned to
the north side of the row
uh about the disease
pressures we thought but uh when we were
doing mechanical harvesting work and uh
rotated the fooding the cross arm to
about a 30° about
horizontal we we were getting a lot less
Japanese Japanese beetle damage because
the uh berries were all kind of hanging
from the the uh
canopy there's another concern though
with the uh fungal problem such as
anthos uh so roll covers must be removed
just prior to Bud break in late winter
or early spring then apply the uh the uh
liquid lime sulfur to control anthos
problems
I'd like to jump in too because there
was a question about insects in the high
tunnel if we get increased insects and
in our experience we get increased mites
that we have to watch out for two
spotted spider mites but otherwise we
have uh very few other problems we've
ever seen no diseases to manage and uh
the only insect or increased mice
because it's drier and warmer in the
tunnel so we do have to pay attention to
mites uh but nothing else and then I
wanted to make a comment too about row
orientation as fumi did we also
recommend positioning our rows uh East
West for the tunnel now if you're doing
field production we recommend north
south orientation because you get better
line interception when the rows are
planted north south so the south side of
the roow and north side of the road get
exposure when the sun comes up in the
East and sets in the west but in a
tunnel particularly late in the season
if you want to get the most light
intercepted when the sun's low in the
south of the sky you want your rose
planted East West so the south side of
the east west row gets the most exposure
to the southern Sun if you're going for
that late there are a couple of
questions I think for Dr teita talking
about training this year's primocane
over the top of next year's
florane um and then wondering about
trellising systems used in in the
primacan production and I'm not I'm not
completely sure um Dr
tequito uh if I understand that question
but
well uh about the uh Prime training over
next
year's or not next year current Year's
florane that's has
fruit I would recommend that the uh this
question they go to the uh some of the
uh
files that they could upload and these
uh reports provide very detailed
uh procedure for manipulating the canes
but what the RC trollis has two wires at
the height of that post the
one training
wire with on the side with a short arm
that is the wire on which the Primal
canes are
trained okay and then the lateral canes
that emerge from the horizontal portion
of the Primal cane are trained to uh or
contain their growth between the uh two
cross arms the main the long cross arm
and the short they got the angle created
with the uh wires on them so you're
trying to
uh keep the prime those lateral canes
growing with with within those two cross
arms or angle created by those two uh
arms of the trellis and then kind of
confine their growth to to more or less
the uh in a vertical uh
Direction okay I hope
that that helps and I do want to draw
everybody's attention while you're in
this phase of the program um you can
click on these different handouts and
bulletins there's quite a number of them
some of them are a little a large but
you can still click on them upload them
right to your computer and I will keep
the digital classroom open so that
people can do that if they like but
you'll also be able to do that from the
archived presentation if you need to log
off um there is a question about the how
level does a site need to to be for a
high tunnel can they be be placed on a
slope um Marvin do you have any thoughts
on
that yeah I see uh a few questions here
for me one is probably a level site is
the most important thing you can have
for a high tunnel when you buy these
kits uh
they're engineered for having a
perfectly level site so if there's one
thing you can do that's make sure that
site is as level as possible it'll go up
a whole lot better and be easier and I
haven't seen anybody placing them on a
slope I think engine from the
engineering point of view it' be just
really hard to support that so level
sight I think is critical uh the Charon
system we used for the primee Blackberry
production that was the system I showed
you where we could basically train the
canes upright but in into a v so we
could bring some of the canes over to
one side and some to the other but for
pric cane blackberries mostly we're just
interested in holding the canes upright
we're not doing a whole lot of
manipulation on primee fru and crops and
then the question on rodents in high
tunnel we're we mowed around the high
tunnels real close to the ground to
Grass before uh fall came and then we
put up chicken wire around the outside
to try to keep the rodents from coming
in and we also tried to secure the
tunnel itself as much as we could um and
we'll just have to keep an eye on it to
make sure it
works oh and a question about the
Chinese method based on on building the
Earth on the north side of the tunnel
and it's built into the slope that's
true I've been to China and I've seen
those but the tunnel itself is still the
soil underneath it it's still Level it's
still flat and they make that arch up
and it goes into the bank uh and it's on
slopes but the part that's planted is
still pretty flat and level at least the
tunnels that I saw over there okay um I
did I I don't know if we answered one
question about venting the tunnel in
September and October and I I do believe
that that's an important thing to be
able to do I I don't know if um you want
to comment on that
Marvin yeah we keep the tunnels vented
almost um I want to say year round but
certainly when there's any amount of
heat that can accumulate in a tunnel you
want to keep it vented and we even on
cold days say November we'll have the
vents open at the top and we'll leave
the sides up maybe 6 in so just to allow
some air movement to come in and move
through so it doesn't get so humid in
there um and then when the really cold
weather comes like we have now we'll
have everything down to the ground and
the vents closed but we try to vent a
fair amount if nothing else to keep the
humidity for moving through because the
plants do better when the humidity is
not too awfully high right um we have
one more question uh for Dr teita which
types of plants should be used erect
semierect
F
me oh sorry yes uh yes uh I I
think both types of varieties could be
trained to RCA
trellis uh even trailing blackberries
work well when the
primes emerge from the crown and they
still 203 25 in tall uh they're all uh
can they all can be bent about 90° to to
force them to grow uh sideways or
horizontally so
uh they all can be trained to RCA
Tris there are some cases where we do
have problems which is are they could
some vigorous primer canes emerge very
early in the season they may be like 1
in in
diameter uh and they they're more
difficult to bend than uh slightly
smaller uh Primal
canes all right um I just put up the
last poll I know that we're a little bit
over on the time but I just think that
the discussion and the questions have
been great and I really appreciate
everybody uh staying in in there for the
full length um if you have any further
questions uh don't hesitate but uh we
are officially done and I I'm going to
leave this so that people can download
the information if you wouldn't mind
just um putting your last um poll
response there that would be helpful and
then our next um webinar will be on
January 20th two weeks from today at the
same time um we will be talking about
weed management in
brambles and you all will be receiving a
email notification about the connection
information prior to that if you know of
people that might enjoy that topic
please don't hesitate to let them know
about the opportunity they do need to to
register separately but we would love to
um continue to grow this program in the
Final Phase of the um webinar Series so
thank you all very much oh somebody
can't can't see all the choices I'm
sorry I'll open that up a little bit
thank you all very much for attending
and thank you mostly to Dr fomi teita
and Dr Marvin pritz uh for your
presentations and enjoy the cold weather
bye
fi I don't know if you see that question
there's a question here from Brent Brett
bindex about um growing a plant that
produces 14 PBS versus a plant that
produces 30 lbs I think what this
individual is talking about is the um
difference between a high tunnel and a
regular
just growing it
outside oh
well I think the question probably is
relates to right cisu which produces 14
PBS compared to triple crown or a patch
that produ 30 so is he still ahead still
I I could answer yeah Brent uh reason
that we're trying to grow cisu in the
eastern United State is that it's a very
early ripening variety uh we could start
harvesting cisu here uh in mid June uh
compared to around July 10th for Apache
and uh triple crown and much later for
some other varieties so by growing
trailing varieties such as cscu one
could extend the picking season uh by uh
2 3 weeks and get the early crop of
BlackBerry before the Japanese beetles
come out of the ground and cause a lot
of problems and if you could pick black
beers earlier in the summer I
think the grower can get higher price
for them for these early varieties well
that answered it for me so I think it
that was great thank you and um I think
that's all the uh yeah I think everybody
is pretty much signing off so again
thank you so much Dr teita and Marvin
and have a great day the rest of you
folks I will leave the classroom on so
that you can continue to download but um
and then this archive will be available
in just a few days on the berry website
as are all the previous eight webinars
plus a few that we did last year and
you're welcome to take a peek at them
and thank you again and we'll see you in
a couple of
weeks
I